hello everyone and welcome to really
it's one of those games that you want to
show your friends and family as soon as
you've seen see them we are gonna take a
short break from the kappa blanka saga
as you really have to see this it's a
game from the second Grand Master Guan
tournament international in 2019 was
played yesterday and it's a game between
international master from India
controller that's not current and Grand
Master from Georgia McHale make it
literally it's a really an intense game
and well more than once our attacker and
earned himself the title of Indian towel
know why he earned himself the title of
Indian towel we'll just have to check
check this game out and see so without
further ado let's just enjoy it
MacLeish really opens with c4 the
English opening with E 5 Knight to c3
Knight to c6 open the reverse Sicilian
line of the English Knight of three with
f5 by black and now g3 preparing to
fianchetto the light square bishop we
have Knight to f6 and now d4 and here
black has to make a choice does he wanna
capture in the center or does he want to
grab more space with E for here
our attacker and goes for more space
with E for and although there are some
games in the database where d5 was
played whitey didn't really have all
that many success all so nice to age for
this is the main line with d5 by black
and now not allowing white to push d5
any anytime soon with Bishop to g5 and
here it's still unknown position D
captures and c4 is a no move here most
notable game where it was played Ivanka
vs Pharaoh save in the hen crease China
in 2019 where were a black one a very
nice game but here we have C we have
Bishop to b4 still it's not a new move
it's a known position III is the main
main idea here well up until now I was
played in the game collision seeker and
vs. Tiger Hill our person but the
Seagram was able to win that game with
black but here we have a different idea
see not III but C captures on d5 it's a
new move
which makes this game even more
interesting because well it's just
it just says that rotten Akron did not
have this prepared so here what do you
do here obviously you have to do
something you can't capture with the
night as your knight is pinned here and
if you capture with the Queen you're
just gonna get a bunch of captions and
f6 your pawn structure on the King side
will be ruined so what to do you play
here well it's true that if you capture
with the knight your queen will be
captured but this is exactly what our
attacker and played Knight captures on
d5 and now you don't really have an
option here you have to capture the
Queen otherwise you're just worst you
just lost the pawn and there's a double
attack against your c3 Knight yes you
could play Bishop d2 but that's just
like admitting you completely missed
this move and you're just gonna be worse
for the rest of the game so here of
course MacLeish really captured the
Queen and now we get Knight captures on
c3 so what happens here of course you
cannot capture the night if you capture
the King has nowhere to go you have to
block with the Queen and after all is
said and done captures captures captures
black would just be up upon and well
again enjoying a much better game so
after Knight chapters on c3 white of
course cannot recapture we have Queen to
b3 now either black will capture here
and then lose castling privileges or if
you capture with the knight then even
the bishop on b4 is under attack so
again when you play here a very
interesting position where you could go
for something like Knight captures on d4
attack the queen force the queen to
capture Bishop denied C to check pick up
the Queen the problem is after King B -
yes you do pick up the Queen but now B
captures and c3 attacks the night
so you either there's no good move here
if you move the knight then a white
moves the bishop and still it doesn't
work if you capture the bishop white
captures the knight and if you come the
pieces white is just up a knight so of
course in a winning game so here after
Queen to b3 ratna currently Knight
captures I need to with a discovered
check it's much better because now you
have to move the King if you capture now
you get to Knight captures and d4 with a
nice clean fork so after the King moves
you get a knight captures here it
captures and after King chapter 78 you
would just have this well
the winner of the board and black is now
just up two points with a much better
position with the bishop pair black
black would win this game so after night
capture sunny - we have King - d1 by
McLeish Willie and now comes the night
he captures on d4 again just getting the
knight back into the game attacking the
Queen white again has to waste a move
moving the Queen Queen - III was played
and now the idea is of K if King
captures then Queen g5 check you can
start picking up some points here on the
Kings side but here at a current doesn't
waste any time
Bishop to e6 really just uh just a
wonderful idea
uh you know just going for the
initiative creating a beautiful game so
what's the idea here you can either move
the door support Kathryn c7 if you
capture on c7 black will get a lot of
development for this rook c8 attack the
Bishop Bishop f4 now you can Castle
kingside
this rope will come to d8 and with this
King still being on d1 it's gonna be one
hell of a game for for white so here
MacLeish really tried a different
approach Bishop to g5 but now Retta
current just plays h6 and now what do
you do here if you move the bishop to f4
then you can get the g5 which wins back
the piece or just a nice queenside
castle once the rogue who gets the d8
and the white it deals with this only
then can you push g5 so here he decided
to retreat Bishop to f6 he gives up the
bishop this way to mess up black's pawn
structure with G captures on f6 and now
keep the c1 just getting his King away
from the D file as of course queenside
castle is coming so our attacker goes
for queenside castle and now Bishop to
h3 he goes after this pawn here with
Bishop to c5 threatening some nice
discoveries here and now Bishop captures
on f5
this was White's plan because now some
Queen Anne ib3 check action is not
possible you will not be winning the
Queen because queen can capture on b3
and you cannot recapture as your Bishop
is pinned here so you would just you
know lose the piece in the game so after
Bishop captures on a 5 we have night cap
trees on f5 not the bishop is unguarded
Bishop Queen captures and c5 Knight
captures and h4g capture
h4 and now rook to d4 black is very
happy with his position he's preparing
rook to the Aged and tabla Brooks and
the D file and while you could argue
that why they still have material one
first you have to you know get your King
to safety and develop this rook and only
then can you even start playing this
game with white with b3 by white and now
rook H to d8 as planned rook to be one
and now Bishop to g4 really controlling
that d1 square we have King Tubby to now
as rook to d1 was the idea and now you
want to hide your King over to a-1 where
it will be much safer here with night
the b4 again really just you know every
move is really really comes as a slap in
the face why is black giving up this a 7
point here it's really hard to
understand because if you capture yes
you do you do get Rudy to check and
after King to a 1 now you could either
go into some weird end game where you
will be objects down the exchange but up
upon and white will have a double H pawn
not not something with black and push
for a win but I think black played this
move simply going for a draw here
because after an IC to chip king be to
Knight back to before checking c1 and
now you just repeat or or you go into
this but I don't think this was the idea
so here white doesn't want to draw here
he doesn't capture on a7 first King to
a-1 doesn't allow Rudie Rudie to to come
with check and now b6 no longer are you
capturing on a7 with Queen to c3 and now
c5 just you know increasing the control
over the B 4 and D four squares with a
three pushing the knight back
ninety-five attacks the Queen and now
Queen to c1 and now h5 just improving
the position the bishop is not nicely
guarded here and now rook to g1 rook to
g1 probably what ideas of as this is a
double pawn you want to play h3 at some
point force the bishop to capture it and
then get your look over to g7 maybe you
could even infiltrate somehow with the
Queen let's say queen f1 may be followed
by Queen
six check and then something so it's a
long plan but perhaps it it it could be
possible here we have looked the d3 now
pressuring the the pond here but really
the idea is just nice to see three and
then followed by of course nice to e2
which would win a lot of material Queen
to see for getting the Queen into the
game here again Queen a6 perhaps you
know the plan could be become possible
but here look the d4 black even offers a
queen to a6 check here although it's not
possible here the line we mentioned for
example Queen a6 check King to be 8 and
now h3 yes
now you if you capture you do get rook
to b7 the problem here for for white is
Knight to c3
and now you don't have a good move here
your rook is under attack if you move it
let's say rook to c1 then you get the
Bishop to e2 and the queen is trapped
the Queen has nowhere to go the knight
guards the bishop and also the a
Foursquare on the other hand if after
Knight to c3 you continue with H
captures and g3 then black doesn't
capture the rook rather rook to d2 and
there's no stopping mate you could
prolong it for example which rook to be
too but then rugby one chip rook b1 and
I'll just the other rook comes here and
it's all over
and again there's no stopping mate here
even if you give up the Queen it will
still be made as rope to a2 will be
checkmate let me just have a nice simple
my water so after rook to d4 with Queen
to c1 not interested in Queen to h6
Queen back to c1 and Outlook d3 with now
not repeating Queen to c4 make it look
really still not interested in a draw
keys the Grand Master here playing
against an international master he wants
to punish his opponents insolent play so
before opening up the lines to the black
King now Knight to c3 as planned and
there are some nice ideas here like 92
just winning material there's no point
in moving the rook
so we have Queen tabby to Knight
captures on be one with rook captures an
b1 and now look to
f 3 we have B captures on c5 and now
rook d2 d3 and here you no longer have
the option of giving up your queen for
some material because now it's rook rook
Bishop against a queen and rook so here
you could you could give up your queen
for two rooks but but no less Queen to
be 5 by white and now comes Luke
captures on a3 with check came to be 2
and now Bishop to d7 just kicking the
Queen away and now again White has to
decide he could play c6 push the bishop
back let's say Bishop to e6 and then
Queen captures on h5 but then you would
get a look to a to check King to c1 and
now King to c7 just blocking that rook
and if Queen to e8 going for an attack
against the bishop and some harassing
radius here and now we just play rook c3
check King to d1 and rook captures and
c6 eliminates this pawn defends the
bishop and our black is just better here
maybe not maybe not if you if you has
the computer but in the inhumans human
play of course black will have the upper
hand here
so after Bishop d7 we have Queen to c4
and now comes Luke to a for attacking
the Queen Queen back to g8 check King
Tubby 7 and now rook to d1 finally White
is able to activate the rook but now
rook captures on f2 with check King to
b3 now rook to f3 check the bishop
guards the rook here so it's not a
problem
King to be 2 and now comes Luke to be
for check King to c1 and now rook the c3
with check King to d2 and only now that
the king is blocking the rooks attack
towards the Bishop rook captures on c5
and now again black is just better here
and now it's black who's up material
plus he has well for
passed pawns so that's also a big plus
we have King to e1 again threatening to
capture the bishop here Bishop to a4
would an attack against the worker Queen
f7 check rook the c7 and now Queen to d5
check Bishop to c6
blocking check and putting the defense
more defense to d4 pawn and now Queen
captures on h5 and here look the g7 with
ideas of rook to be 2 followed by rooked
one checkmate we have looked a d6 here
and here after Luke 2 B 2 it was in this
position that georgian grandmaster miko
make it looks really resigned to the
game why did he resign well it's just
too hard to play this rook the d2 rook
g1 is the threat of checkmate play
something like can you find you get
Bishop b5 check and now again you have
to move the king and allow checkmate or
you will give up the Queen so that's
also not something you want to do on the
other hand after rook to be - you could
try rook to d2 now if rooms you want
check you will be able to run back with
the King but again black will just
prepare it and everything will be fine
for example if rook did you want check
you will play King to f2 attacking the
rook and now you don't want to play
something like captures captures and III
this will not work it seems like it's
completely winning for black but it's
actually not King f1 and I need to check
you're just gonna go king he won and
it's hard to find where you're gonna go
with the rug because you can't keep on
defending be to pawn if you go something
like locate to Queen f7 check picks up
the rook so pretty much the same if you
go here again you get Queen Queen h7
check now and now what do you do here if
you stay on the last two rings you will
get you know harassed by perpetual
checks if you go here then you will get
this check once you go back white just
repeats and if you go here or block with
the bishop then it's just we need three
picks up the rug so not the way you want
to play this how you want to play this
is that after this rook - D - you want
to play rook the g1 check right away not
to network did you want about rook the
b1 check right away and now after
something like came to f2 now you play
rook the b3 threatening III the win the
rook here and only after kinky - now you
play rook to f3 now preparing rook to G
- and after rook to d6 getting the rock
out of the way
rook to g2 check King to e1 and now
you're gonna go look to a3 and now
really there's not all that much now
mate is properly properly prepared if
Queen f7 check you're gonna go King
gauge 6f queen sex
going after the pond just Bishop b5 also
the bishop is under attack and after
capture Syria just the rookie one check
there's nothing more white could have
done catchers not here obviously
captures here and now it's all over for
white but McLeish really saw that even
with the most precise play there's no
way he could get out of this so after
this rope to be to move he resigned the
game and a wonderful wonderful victory
by contoller that knocker on the Indian
towel really after that game by Morley
Karthik in sacrificing his queen
brilliantly it's I think in the article
by Chas bass in the other mentioned it's
a like eight or nine days after that
game but just a wonderful wonderful
chest so I do hope you enjoyed it
let's just see it one more time you know
so to say in slow motion after C capture
some b5 we had night captures and d5 and
this is just this is just beautiful so
let's leave it that did that like I said
I do hope you enjoyed it do check out
the article by chess base India it will
be the first link you've seen the
description below where they talk a bit
more about the Indian tile control it's
not current they there are some other
games played by him you really want to
check them out and you know we we might
even share a nice series on him in the
future as he really has some very
exciting games so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Paul rod and the Frank combs Edwin
Park Katy Alberico and willpotter for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot and to answer your question mr. Park
I am from Croatia
if if that is not known so there's that
and yeah as usual you can check to my
previous videos so your thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the Capablanca saga checking
up on your suggestions such as this one
thank you for that and you know just
doing what we usually do thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day